foreign
if you're building web apps you'll
surely love Firebase I know I do
Firebase hosting has a powerful CDN and
makes it simple to configure custom
domains
and then there are many other features
to love like managed user authentication
and extensions that make it easy to send
email or resize images
on Google Cloud the easiest and most
convenient place to run backend code is
cloud run
it lets you run your code written in any
programming language directly on top of
Google's scalable infrastructure
building web applications with Google
cloud and Firebase makes a lot of sense
until now using Firebase hosting and
Cloud run together required multiple
steps to set up we fixed that and as of
today you can integrate Firebase hosting
with Cloud run in one click well maybe
two
let me show you how to build a web
application with Firebase and Google
Cloud using a demo
here's my new blog you can scroll
through all the recent posts and if you
sign in you can subscribe to a weekly
digest email
yeah I know this is a classic and
Timeless example but you'll still learn
a lot from it because this is everything
I will cover in this video using any
programming language with Cloud run
adding a domain and a global CDN with
Firebase hosting
storing data in firestore adding user
authentication with Firebase and
scheduling a recurring job with clever
and jobs in Cloud scheduler and sending
emails with Firebase
let's get started
[Music]
on Google cloud cloud run is a great
place for your backend code it lets you
run your code directly on top of
Google's scalable infrastructure
and you can use any programming language
on cloud run I really like to use the
programming language go so that's what I
use as a backend for my blog
my backend code renders HTML and sends
it to the browser my blog's data is
stored in firestore
that's a document or in the database and
I like that it's incredibly reliable
Google offers a 99.99 SLA for
multi-regional locations
that's the service level agreement of
five nines now that's reliable
this is my blog's code it's fairly
minimal as you can see it has a few go
files and just a Sprinkle of JavaScript
and CSS there's also a Docker file the
docker file describes how to build and
package my app into a container image
that's useful because containers can run
anywhere
if you don't like to write and maintain
Docker files Club run also lets you do a
source based deployment and that means
Cloud run figures out how to build and
package your app into a container
without requiring a Docker file
let's deploy my blog I navigate to the
cloud run page in the Google Cloud Web
console and click create service
I have the source code of my blog stored
in GitHub so I'll select continuously
deploy new revisions from a source
across 3 and set up Cloud build
that brings up this panel
I can select a repository I want to use
and I have a Docker file so that's what
I select here Club run also suggests
using Google Cloud buildbacks if you
don't have a Docker file but let's save
let's call my service fictional blog
that sounds good and I'll select a
region close to me here in Europe one
that has low CO2 because that's
important
and there are more settings here I can
configure CPU allocation and auto
scaling oh and I want to allow an
authenticated invocations to make sure
that my blog is publicly available
it's now deploying
before we continue there's one thing I
want to emphasize here
you can use any programming language on
cloud run because it's container based I
used go because I like it but I could
have used Java node.js python Ruby PHP
or any other language
Cloud run only needs a container to
start a web server and handle incoming
requests or events
let's take a look at that deployment
again it's still running and look it's
ready Club run deployed my blog
it's ready on an https endpoint I click
on the URL to see it in action
and it worked so there's my blog I
should write a blog post now but look at
the URL it's the cloud run default
endpoint it has a unique cache in the
zip domain and I don't really want to
use that as the URL for my blog so let's
change that
to add my domain I'll use Firebase
hosting
it comes with a web.apsip domain and I
can pick any subdomain that's still
available
it also comes with a built-in content
delivery Network a CDN and the ability
to use my own custom domain later if I
wanted to
now there's an alternative which is to
use cloud load balancing on Google Cloud
and that's a good option if you need
Advanced features such as multi-regional
Cloud run deployments or Integrations
with other Google cloud services like
Cloud armor
I don't need any of that so I'm gonna go
with Firebase hosting
I will set up Firebase hosting using the
Google Cloud console and this is the
part that we're launching today adding
Firebase hosting to Cloud run service is
now one click in the Integrations tab
click add integration
and select Firebase hosting
now I enter the zip domain I like
fictional blog.web.app sounds about
right
Cloud run is Now setting up Firebase
hosting for me previously I would have
had to complete multiple steps and read
through documentation to set this up
properly
it looks like claron needs some time
here so let's talk about Firebase
hosting in more depth
earlier I mentioned that Firebase
hosting has a global CDN and you might
wonder why that's important
a CDN is a great way to improve the
performance of your site because it
stores frequently requested data on an
edge location that's closer to the user
than the cloud run services and this
improves end user response times it
makes your site faster
let's check if Cloud run has already
added Firebase hosting in front of my
blog oh it looks like it is completed my
blog is now available on fictional
blog.web.app which is a better URL than
the one in Cloud run and I can also
change this to my own custom domain
later using the Firebase console
one thing to note here is that to make
good use of this caching ability of the
CDN you should include cache control
headers in responses like I'm doing here
public tells shared cash is that the
response is cachable don't set that for
private Pages max age tells your browser
to Cache no longer than 30 seconds and
the S max age tells shared caches such
as the CDN to Cache no longer than 60
Seconds
all my blog's data is stored in Cloud
firestore which is a document or in the
database from Firebase and Google Cloud
it's for mobile web and server
development
today I'll connect to it for my code on
cloud run
let's return to the demo and add a first
post
here is my blog again with no posts I'll
navigate to firestore in the Google
Cloud Web console and add the first post
I pick native mode that's the
recommended mode for firestore datastore
mode is only needed if you are migrating
from datasort
I choose a multi-regional location in
Europe and they have better availability
than Regional locations but it's also
more expensive
I'll now add a new collection called
posts and in this collection we'll have
a document for each post on my blog
I add a first post
it's a document with two Fields there's
content and markdown
I make it say hello world first post
and I also have to set a a publish date
which I'll set to now because I want to
see my first post live
immediately
I click save and go back to my blog
and this is great my first post is live
now
now let's allow my readers to sign in to
subscribe to the weekly digest email by
adding Firebase Authentication
I will add only a Google one tab sign in
button but Firebase authentication
supports many identity providers
this is the Firebase console let's set
up Google want app sign in here I click
setup sign in method as you can see
there are many available sign-in
providers here I click Google and enable
it to get the button to work on my blog
I added a few API keys in other settings
that you can copy from the Firebase
console
now when users readers of my blog click
sign in to subscribe
take us to the sign in page
I click the button consent to logging in
and there you go I'm logged into my my
own blog I'll make sure to subscribe to
the weekly digest of my own blog because
I really like to receive email
let's dive into what just happened under
the hood
with Firebase authentication you can
sign in users with only client-side code
when the user presses the sign in with
Google button it kicks off the sign-in
flow
the user consents to logging in and
identity provider shares the user
details with Firebase and Firebase
returns an identity token to the browser
to complete the sign-inflow the
client-side code passes the identity
token to the back end in Cloud run using
a post request
and the backend then uses the Firebase
admin SDK to verify the token get the
user details and set an HTTP only
session cookie to make sure the user
stays logged in
now that we've covered user login let's
talk about implementing that Weekly
digest email
now the most straightforward way to
implement that is to write some code
that does three things
pool list of recipients from firestore
formats the email and send all the
emails let's take a look at the code
I can query the list of recipients from
firestore when I clicked subscribe
earlier it added the record to a
collection called preferences
you can see it here in the Firebase
console it shows subscribe is through
and that's my user ID
so in my code when I get the list of
emails I can filter unsubscribed here
and I use the user ID to query the email
using the Firebase authentication SDK
and the third step is to use a Firebase
extension to send the emails I'll show
you how shortly
I'll also need to execute that code once
every week
here's a good way to implement a
recurring job on Google Cloud use cloud
run jobs to run the code use cloud
scheduler to execute it every week and
use a Firebase extension to easily send
email
that's it Cloud run jobs is Grand for
the cloud
this is the cloud run interface again I
can create a job here like there are
services and jobs
two different tabs now when I press
create job
earlier I configured automatic
deployments from GitHub and I can reuse
the same container image for my job
because I added a second entry point to
the container that runs the code that
sends the emails
I select a container image
and
let's call this job weekly Digest
I set it to run in the same region in
Europe where my service runs
and this is where I can configure the
second entry point
now this is how that works in my Docker
file I build a second binary called job
and that runs the logic to send the
emails
so I set that container command to run
the binary
and I set my job to execute immediately
now let's take a look at the logs
Ah that's great it looks like I got my
first email
now I want to schedule this on a weekly
schedule
so I go to this rarest Tab and click add
scheduler trigger
I can add a schedule for this job to run
on every Monday
I like that this field legend that it
changes when I type to help me figure
out how this Grand job format works so
it should be zero nine star star one and
that's at 9am on every Monday
I created the trigger and now it runs on
every Monday morning
to wrap up this part I want to highlight
that there are two main resources in
Cloud run
services are for web services Cloud run
provides an https endpoint and handles
all incoming requests using a web server
that you provide in a container image
and this is what we did at the beginning
of the demo
now jobs are used to run code that
performs a job and quits when the work
is done compiling and sending the weekly
digest is the perfect use case for jobs
I want to quickly show how to add the
extension so this is the Firebase
console again I navigate to the list of
extensions
there are several extensions available
and I picked the send email extension by
Firebase
it wants to create some resources in my
project and that's okay
I also have to configure my SMTP server
I'll fill in some made up values here
and replace them later when you're not
watching me type
I click next and there we go it's
installing
this is how I use the extension to send
an email
I write a document in a mail collection
with the subject and the email body
and the recipient
that's it
and this is what happens if I add a new
record to the mail collection if I'm
quick enough I can see that the email
extension adds a new field
to the document with the delivery info
and it looks like it succeeded and
delivered my email using just one
attempt
if there's one thing to remember from
watching this video it's this it's great
to build web applications with Google
cloud and Firebase
Firebase has a powerful CDN and many
more features to love it works together
well with Cloud run which is a great
place for your backend code
thank you
[Music]
foreign